as his troops lose ground in Ukraine how
is Russia's commander-in-chief digesting
this latest setback and what does he
have planned looking forward
because on Russia's talk shows there's a
definite sense of unease
this was last Friday as the scale of
Ukraine's counter-offensive sunk in most
of people absolutely must have been
who's often brought on as the token
liberal tells me he was surprised at the
change in tone everybody
both people who is against the military
operation and both people who is poor
military operation said something goes
wrong
so what do you think will happen if
Russia keeps losing if the ukrainians
keep pushing on I think you should not
over appreciate the results of Ukrainian
Army last days like this because the
military potential of Russia Federation
is very big and practically was not
significantly used in Ukrainian this
time do you think he'd use a nuclear
weapon tactical nuclear weapon I think
it is it has very low probability
practically no probability a very bad
situation will be if Ukrainian Army
begins to destroy some objects on Russia
Federation
this will be very bad
very bad
is Vladimir Putin aware of the realities
on the ground the Kremlin says so is
there more that he could throw at this
definitely is the domestic pressure
building to an extent that he should be
worried probably not yet these are
murmurings of disquiet they are not a
chorus things would have to get quite a
lot worse if kevson were to fall if
Crimea were to look like it were at risk
then that might be a different story
but I believe Timothy nikolaev and
vasili khada shilov were both until
elections last weekend local councilors
in Moscow
nicolaev's Final Act to write this
appeal to Russia's Parliament asking
Vladimir Putin to resign
do you think it will change anything
I don't expect any changes I would I
would see
but
um you can't know what his last straw or
a kennel's back
the man in the Kremlin won't go because
of them they know that and he's sitting
pretty for now but if the unraveling on
the ground continues will he for that
much longer
dynamagne Sky News Moscow